it is my understanding that harry has
come over to europe he's made this
detour to the uk very much wanting to
meet with some of his family um he was
very keen to see his grandmother he's
very keen to see his father and that he
is hoping that these talks will be the
beginning of
a thought in what up until now has been
a very icy relationship and harry i'm
told suggested perhaps that they might
get some sort of a mediator in on these
talks to make some progress it was
something that he has suggested to his
father he's made it very clear that he
he wants to sort things out he wants
things to be improved i'm hearing that
he wants to be over here for the queen's
platinum jubilee celebrations in june
i think possibly that suggestion of a
mediator is probably less for the
relationship with his father because his
father is open to wanting to sort things
out i would imagine it's more to do with
his brother that idea of wanting a
mediator is probably more to do with him
and william whose relationship really is
you know at a bit of a crossroads they
haven't spoken for many months they're
not close at the moment it has been very
very difficult that sort of hope of a
rapprochement i think is is much further
off for william and harry far more so
than it is for harry and his father i
think people will read into william
perhaps deliberately not being here in
that same week that his brother was
coming over i i don't think it was
deliberately staged like that personally
and
william and kate have a limited period
of holiday over the easter they wanted
to take the children's skiing i think
what was made clear was that when
harry's trip was confirmed and it was
all going ahead
william wasn't going to change his own
holiday plans to come back or cut short
his holiday in order to see his brother
and don't forget when william had a
party over here last year to thank those
who've been involved with the diana
statue he didn't actually invite harry
to that he didn't ask him to come back
over from the states for it so i think
that gives you some indication as to how
tense and how difficult that
relationship is and that may well be why
harry suggested to his father that they
may need some something of a mediator in
all of this because the sticky
relationship here the one that's much
harder to get back on an even track is
william and harry's
[Music]
you